[Music]
oh hi al it's Dasia and i'm here to talk
about halloween one of my favorite times
of the year that also happens to be
ruined by racist ass hats who think that
they have the winning response for why
blackface is okay in 2016 in the wise
words of Kanye you ain't got the answers
and you never will
[Music]
it's meet me at the zoo in the morning
at 9 o'clock yeah we're the rest of the
monkey with the rest of the monkey I'll
bring my ground ball with I decided to
play a game with my coworkers
to see if they can see why blackface is
so unnecessary in 2016 and 2017 2018
you know what just forever I had a model
come in and dress up as for permanent
black celebrities given that the
argument is that we'd never ever ever
ever ever ever be able to know who these
celebrities are because the people
wearing the costumes aren't black I
actually wanted to see if that was true
I'm thinking this is like an early days
of Miley Cyrus the plaid shirt looks
like Al Boylan from home improvement
looks like a nice blonde hipster beyond
thick I think it'd be honest I think of
the leotards I think of like iconic
stuff from her music videos so this was
the outfit from her flawless video oh
I'm so bad I'm not big enough Beyonce
fan that's my fault
what gave it away for you this so if
this is her costume she needs to be like
this lab a long Oh easy Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson
how could that be anyone but Michael
Jackson I'm gonna say this is Michael
Jackson although it also could be Eddie
Murphy from his rock climbing for the
win
what gave it away for you the jacket
Walt's an iconic outfit almost easy
already this is Prince definitely Prince
Prince so you would say Prince final
answer
absolutely okay Prince what about this
allowed you to get that it was Prince
the glasses the hair the outfit again
the pirate shirt that's pretty classic
Prince Diana Ross Dolly Parton that is
Diana Ross sing what's love got to do
with it no okay that might be your
problem
just Tina Turner Tina Tina Tina who to
turn yeah there is the only one win that
winner you get a beautiful yeah
you know I don't like [ __ ] like this
so the whole reason why I brought you
here is that it's Halloween season and
it's very common for people to want to
dress up as iconic people and iconic
black people the issue is though is that
a lot of people then feel justified in
using blackface really yeah why do you
think some people feel so compelled to
use blackface even though they know it's
offensive it's funny it's something I've
never grown up with the thought of being
an option exactly right
where people need to be raised like I
think that people think that oh yeah
it's just my costume and they don't
realize like the historical significance
of blackface and what it means they've
never had that done to them so they
don't understand the gravity of the
situation I know this might feel like a
strange question but did you ever feel
like when we went through the pictures
that you needed blackface to understand
who these people were
No so you struggled with a few of them
and like with those that you struggled
with like do you think that them being
in blackface would have helped you
anything no I think my lack of
understanding pop culture was is a
definite divider
these people aren't iconic for their
race their iconic for their hair they're
iconic for their style their iconic for
their dance smooth the better your
actual costume is the less you have to
do anywhere else right answer is not
being like only I was brown they would
have gotten it it's like no you then you
would have offended a lot of people guys
100 100 percent blackface is never okay
it'll never be okay it's not okay it
wasn't okay but that's just how it is
y'all girly is taking me to church with
this sermon over here like if people
don't recognize it from what you're
wearing then it's probably it's a bad
costume so just to recap some of the
major tips that were offered as
alternatives to blackface your look
needs to be super duper iconic in the
words of Claudia if nobody knows who you
are it's because your costume is shitty
and not because you needed blackface for
people to understand tip number two
iconic actions and phrases are your
friends when done not offensively
there's a line there folks
and tip number three it never hurts to
just tell people who you are I mean it
just saves you a whole lot more
controversy than using blackface just to
be clear blackface is not and will never
be something that's okay to do ever
there are so many more fun and creative
ways to honor your favorite black
celebrities without dehumanizing an
entire race at the same time
real talk actual blackness is magical
and you can't cheaply imitate something
this magical so with that have a happy
and non racist Halloween everyone
don't do blackface yay but for real
don't do it just don't do it you don't
want to be don't be the one don't do it
just don't do it